we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that is making i don't know a
point i don't i don't want to evaluate
it until we listen to it but it is
making a point about roseanne bars sort
of explanation not excuse but
explanation for her comments related to
the sleep medication ambien let's take a
listen to the voicemail bar but there
has been some extremely weird things
people have done went on and ii and like
murder people drive a car have sex on
their sleep
i mean it's certainly possible but it's
still no excuse what she said right i
think that's the point which is there's
no denying that ambien can cause unusual
behavior in people but it's not going to
cause someone who doesn't think racist
things to all of a sudden think racist
things right so if we're going to talk
about ambien as an explanatory factor in
what Roseanne did it would be that it
might have disinhibited her in a way
that she decided to get on twitter and
tweet the racist things that she already
thinks but the idea you know it's the
Mel Gibson thing right no matter how
much I drink I'm not going to start
using the n-word and saying bad things
about black people because I don't
believe those things no matter how much
ambient I take and I guess that's not
even the right way to say it because you
would who takes extremely high it's just
you either take ambien or you don't it's
pretty binary it's not going to make me
all of a sudden believe things that I
don't believe all of those might be
disinhibited substances but they're not
going to make me all of a sudden think
that Asians are a major problem in
society if it's not something that I
already think and that's I think what is
being missed here and if you know that
ambien lowers your inhibitions and makes
you say wacky crazy things move your
phone away from the bed exactly sign out
of your Twitter account before you take
it I mean there's yeah there's ways
around this nobody's denying ambien can
cause unusual behavior but the idea that
it makes you racist is absolutely
pathetic we've got a great bonus show
for you today we'll rule
talk about the downfall of rising
Republican star Republican Missouri
governor Eric Greitens we will talk
about a woman caught shaving her legs at
a public pool in Florida and we will
also talk about Walmart's new initiative
for all employees who have been with
them 90 days or more college for a
dollar a day as long as it's one of
three online schools and we will talk
about which schools those are on today's
bonus show get access to the bonus show
sign up at join pakman.com or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show